Des murs cyclopéens, un merveilleux masque
d'or, une guerre lancée pour venger l'enlèvement
d'une jeune princesse, ce sont les échos
de la cité de Mycènes.
Mycènes c’est la capitale du royaume d’Agamemnon,
le roi légendaire qui guide les Achéens,
c’est-à-dire les Grecs du continent contre
Troie et ses alliés.
A jamais marquée par le portrait d’or qu’on
lui a prêté, la véritable identité du
roi Agamemnon nous échappe. Il persiste chez
les visiteurs une confusion entre le récit
homérique et les vestiges archéologiques
de Mycènes. Pourtant, pour qui essaye de
faire correspondre les événements de l’Iliade
avec la chronologie, un fait apparaît clairement:
Agamemnon, s’il a régné sur Mycènes,
l’a fait vers 1200 avant notre ère, soit
quelques années seulement avant le déclin
et l’abandon de la cité.
Sans doute l’un de ses derniers souverains, il n’est en
aucun cas l’artisan de sa grandeur.
La date du règne ne concorde pas non plus
avec la datation du masquequ’on lui attribue
incompatibilité dont se moque par définition
le mythe, ce n’est pas son rôle.
Le mythe s’attache davantage à décrire la lignée
du roi, ses stratagèmes d’héritier
et ses aventures guerrières.
Pour venger le rapt d’Hélène, femme de son frère Ménélas, souverain de Sparte,
Agamemnon prend la tête d’une formidable expédition militaire
qui assiège Troie pendant
dix ans.
Victorieux grâce à la colère d’Achille
et à la ruse d’Ulysse, les Achéens rentrent
au pays avec leur butin.
Homère raconte alors qu’Agamemnon
est assassiné de retour à Mycènes, par
sa femme Clytèmnestre, vengeant le sacrifice
de leur fille Iphigénie.
Au-delà de cette sombre histoire de famille
subsiste donc une figure mythique, celle d’Agamemnon,
général victorieux de la guerre la plus
glorieuse et légendaire, souverain associé
à Zeus lui-même, figure d’autorité inégalable,
bien que marqué par la violence et la cruauté.
A l’époque à laquelle chante le poète
Homère, au VIIIe siècle avant notre ère,
Agamemnon est un personnage des temps anciens.
Presque cinq siècles les séparent.
Évoquer Mycènes et son roi légendaire
c’est donc déjà éprouver le vertige du temps.
La Guerre de Troie à laquelle Agamemnon participe est
un récit qui se perd dans la nuit des Temps,
le temps des héros et des dieux, déjà révolu
depuis longtemps.
En réalité, on l’a dit, si jamais un dénommé
Agamemnon a bien régné sur Mycènes, les
vestiges les plus remarquables ne sont pas
de son époque.
Mycènes est une relique de l’âge du Bronze.
Les premières constructions sur le site de
la forteresse peuvent être attribuées à
des chefs-guerriers qui s’y sont installés
au XVIIe siècle avant notre ère et qui importèrent
massivement de l'or dans leur cité vraisemblablement
depuis l’Égypte.
Ils nous sont connus par
leurs tombes et celles de leurs descendants
qui ont fait la renommée du site.
Un grand cercle de tombes de 28 m de diamètre
entouré d'un enclos constitue la nécropole
royale. Il faut imaginer cet espace rempli
de terre, avec à l’intérieur, 6 tombes
contenant 19 squelettes.
Les corps étaient placés avec leurs parures et des petites offrandes, la plupart en or
épées, poignards, diadèmes, brassards
et plus de 850 disques
d'or gravés servant sans doute de parure aux vêtements
Le prestige des objets retrouvés
ne permet pas de douter,
c’est une élite qui s’est fait enterrer là.
Dans les premières années de la fouille, dirigée par Heinrich Schliemann
à partir
de 1876, la nécropole a livré 14 kg d'objets en or.
Au moment de cette découverte, la
nécropole est donc attribuée à Agamemnon
et à ses proches, victimes d’un complot
à leur retour de Troie.
Le fameux masque en or, artefact le plus prestigieux représenterait alors
Agamemnon lui-même.
A l’extérieur de l’enceinte, 9 tholoi,
des tombes à coupole, ont été bâties.
Atteignant 14 mètres de hauteur, grâce à
la technique de l’encorbellement, elles
abritaient aussi des défunts de l’aristocratie
mycénienne.
Par coquetterie ou par vantardise,
les fouilleurs les ont aussi attribuées à
la dynastie mythique d’Agamemnon, sans que
cela ne soit plus justifié.
Plus visibles
que celles de la forteresses, ces sépultures
ont malheureusement toutes été pillées
avant d’être étudiées.
Elles sont le témoignage du dernier état des tombes princières à Mycènes,
datées du XIIIe siècle avant notre ère.
"9 mètres de long, pesant quelques 120 tonnes"
Mais Mycènes n’est pas qu’un cimetière.
Mycènes est avant tout une citadelle, située
sur un promontoire, qui domine la riche plaine
d’Argos, et entourée de remparts aux murs épais.
C'est une cité forteresse avec en
son centre le palais royal.
Pour y accéder, une porte principale, la
très célèbre Portes des Lions, qui tire
son nom du relief qui la décore.
Les félins
gardent l’édifice et leurs têtes fixent
le visiteur qui se rend au palais.
Ces lions
affrontés sont ainsi devenus l’emblème
de la ville, et préfigurant les blasons du
Moyen-âge, devaient constituer les armoiries
de la dynastie régnante.
Le palais, lui, est situé au sommet de la citadelle.
Par palais, il faut entendre une
grande cour à ciel ouvert avec un sol à
l’origine recouvert d'un enduit à motifs.
Le palais était centré
sur un ensemble de trois pièces, qui constituaient
l’espace de réception où le pouvoir royal
se mettait en scène.
Mycènes ne livre pas de vestiges d’une
agglomération autour de la citadelle.
Il est probable que le site n’ait été réservé
qu’au pouvoir, à sa mise en scène dans
la vie comme dans la mort, et que la population
ait vécu plus bas dans la plaine.
Un argument qui étaye cette hypothèse est
qu’il n'y a pas de source dans l'enceinte
de la forteresse ni sur l’ensemble de la
colline.
Des puits et des réservoirs ont été construits pour récupérer les eaux
de pluie
mais cela ne permettait pas un approvisionnement
suffisant pour une population importante ou
même en cas de siège.
Mycènes était donc la nécropole-capitale
d’un royaume parmi d’autres,
dans la Grèce dite «mycénienne».
La cité a donné son nom à la culture de l’Age du Bronze
qui s’étend jusqu’aux rives de l’Asie
mineure et de la Crète.
La civilisation mycénienne s’effondre au
début du XIIe siècle. En l’espace de deux
décennies, tous les royaumes de Méditerranée
orientale sont victimes de destructions.
A Mycènes, un incendie détruisit le palais,
vers 1190.
Après ça, le site est abandonné,
et le palais n’est pas reconstruit.
Souvent
attribuées à des mystérieux «peuples de la Mer »
nom que leur donne les textes
égyptiens,
ces destructions marquent la fin d’une époque.
Plus qu’une invasion brutale
et sans lendemain, il faudrait plutôt voir
dans cet effondrement généralisé du monde
égéen de l’Age du Bronze des causes complexes
et entremêlées: épidémies, migrations,
révoltes, sans doute agrémentés d’un
épuisement économique et fiscal.
Au début du XIIe siècle avant notre ère,
le royaume du mythique Agamemnon, sombre comme
les autres dans le passé. Seulement à la
différence de Cnossos ou d’Akrotiri, ce
site n’a jamais été oublié et redécouvert
le récit homérique l’a gardé dans la mémoire humaine.
Les pierres des murs cyclopéens,
trop massives pour être transportées sans
mobiliser des centaines de personnes, ont
empêché les populations locales de les réutiliser.
Ce site, comme celui de Cnossos est à comprendre
dans son contexte historique. Et par contexte,
il ne faut pas comprendre l’Age du Bronze,
mais bien le 19e siècle de notre ère.
Les archéologues européens lancés dans la redécouverte de l’Antiquité
sont à cette époque en concurrence
et tentent de mettre au jour les
vestiges des cités glorieuses
dont tout le monde a entendu parler
Troie, le labyrinthe
du Minotaure, Delphes, Mycènes…
A la clé: de la visibilité comme on dirait
de nos jours, des financements pour leurs
travaux, une belle carrière universitaire
et une postérité éternelle…
Trouver le «masque d’Agamemnon», c’est acquérir
une partie de sa renommée
voilà pourquoi Schliemann, le fouilleur de Mycènes,
a peut-être un peu enjolivé ses trouvailles.
« masque d’Agamemnon» est indéniablement plus
vendeur que le numéro de matricule donné par le musée
«NM 624»
Mycènes comme plusieurs autres sites grecs
ont acquis cette aura mystique héritée de
la mythologie parce que les archéologues
qui les fouillaient à la fin du XIXe siècle
en étaient largement imprégnés.
C’était la plus grande des finalités, exhumer enfin
les palais et les rois qu’ils avaient croisés
à de nombreuses reprises pendant leurs études
classiques.
Il est fort peu probable que ce masque, voire que ce palais
ait été celui
du roi qui déclencha la guerre de Troie,
car on ne possède aucune trace d’un roi
de ce nom en dehors de la mythologie.
Mais après tout, cette appellation a au moins
permis de faire connaître cette cité au
grand public
Et puis, le site de Mycènes
avec ses remparts et ses tombes monumentales
est tellement exceptionnel et majestueux,
qu’on comprend finalement l’enthousiasme
de Schliemann.
Attribuer à la forteresse
un occupant aussi légendaire qu’Agamemnon,
c’est finalement lui faire une faveur,
c’est lui rendre hommage.